bonjour à vous et merci de nous
rejoindre dans ce lieu magnifique le
musée girodet de montargis un musée qui
vous propose ce week end des journées
portes ouvertes
après six années de travaux et les
terribles inondations de juin 2016 et
louise et oui et pour l'occasion on vous
propose cette émission spéciale giraud
des sauvés des eaux
on est ensemble pendant près de 30
minutes on va vous raconter l'histoire
très mouvementée de ce lieu vous le
faire découvrir en avant première vous
allez voir c'est un site d'exception
tout de suite
[Musique]
quand
yu
et nous voilà en direct depuis le très
joli parc du musée giraud d ici au coeur
de montargis où on a de la chance un
rayon de soleil nous accompagne pour
cette émission spéciale et nos deux
invités
pascal gardès directrice du musée
bonjour bonjour à vos côtés jean pierre
door député du loiret bonjour merci
d'être avec nous et louise bruzat nous
accompagne aussi depuis l'intérieur du
musée pour nous faire vivre les
coulisses
héloïse gatille beaucoup de monde pour
ces journées portes ouvertes bonjour
rebecca et bien écoutez ça arrive au
compte-gouttes mais je pense que vous
devez vous rendre vous en rendre compte
là où vous êtes placé comme il ya du
soleil les gens préfèrent pour le moment
admirer le superbe bâtiment depuis
l'extérieur ils vont bientôt rentrer ici
dans ces salles puisque entre
aujourd'hui jusqu'à 19 heures et demain
entre 10h et 19h il y a cet espace là à
découvrir
il n'y a pas encore beaucoup des oeuvres
accrochées sur les murs mais donner à
des restaurateurs qui sont là justement
pour vous expliquer un petit peu le
travail qu'ils ont fait et je suis
persuadé que les montargois vont affluer
parce que c'est un site qui leur est
chère qu'il aura beaucoup manqué ces six
dernières années donc l'atmosphère je
vous ai sûr il ya dans l'atmosphère il
ya vraiment beaucoup de fierté et
d'impatience merci beaucoup et louise on
vous retrouve tout à l'heure jean pierre
door parce qu'elle gardait ce qu'est ce
que ça vous fait de voir ce musée ouvert
au public après de si longues années
fermeture si vous me posez la question à
moi je suis très heureux c'est tellement
attendu depuis six années de fermeture
petit à petit on construisait ce musée
le jour on a voulu l'ouvrir on a eu
patatras les inondations qui nous ont
retardé d'un an un an et demi en plus
donc aujourd'hui on est très fiers
d'avoir ce musée ouvert parce qu'elle
gardait ce également bruit et bien sûr
beaucoup de fierté de c'est un long un
long travail en effet même avant les
inondations
reconstruire un projet de rénovation et
de structures à restructuration musée
est assez lourd en effet donc c'est la
concrétisation de tout ce travail plus
le surmonter une épreuve comme celle de
ces inondations ces terribles
inondations
on va revenir sur cet événement qui a
bouleversé toute la ville de montargis
on s'en souvient il ya deux ans en juin
2016 le musée girodet qui porte le nom
d'ailleurs de ce célèbre peintre
montargois a payé un lourd tribut dans
la catastrophe à 80% des oeuvres des
collections se sont retrouvés sous l'eau
on va revenir en images sur cet
événement avec julien bernier et
françois bellot et on se retrouve juste
après avec nos invités
les collections restaurer font leur
retour au musée au compte gouttes
ces oeuvres reviennent de loin au
printemps 2016 les réserves où elle
était stockée se sont retrouvées
inondées de l'eau devenue le cauchemar
du musée girodet à montargis depuis
qu'elle s'est engouffré par cette grille
dans les réserves où étaient stockés
près de trois mille oeuvres qu'il faut
remonter une à une pour constater les
dégâts
celle-ci est peut-être perdu là il a
passé deux jours dans l'eau donc il va
falloir faire un premier état des lieux
pour savoir ce qu'il en est et qu'elles
sont et et les conséquences de cette
immersion loué la boue ont impacté plus
de 80% des 3000 oeuvre face au désastre
des restaurateurs bénévoles ont donné
les premiers soins
la boue qui a été déposée avec l'eau
afin d'éviter que la vie ne sèche avec
cette pellicule en surface celle ci ne
viennent donc s'incruster dans l'oeuvre
est aussi qu'elle ne soit une source de
nutriments pour le micro-organisme c'est
ce qu'on veut sur toile
après des mois de séchage les
collections ont été confiés à des
ateliers de restauration
le coût estimé dépasse le million
d'euros pascal gardait ce qu'est ce que
ça vous fait de revoir ces images c'est
toujours très impressionnant c'est vrai
que là là on a toujours une difficulté à
surmonter un effet les les événements et
les réactions que nous avons eues à ce
moment là mais nous sommes en vous avez
vécu justement ces moments ah bah écoute
et on les jeux je les ai vécus en effet
par rapport à la montée des eaux plutôt
à la submersion des réserves transitoire
puisque le musée est en chantier les
collections étaient déplacés et gt grâce
à un pompier en effet évacué en dernière
urgence avant que que l'eau ne pénètre
totalement dans ses réserves
et du côté de la municipalité jean
pierre door vous étiez maire de la ville
à l'époque on sait que vous étiez très
occupé aussi à gérer tous les sinistrés
de montargis parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
mais concernant ce musée vous avez parlé
à l'époque d'une catastrophe culturelle
oui tout à fait je pense même qu'on a eu
des larmes aux yeux
on en pleurerait de voir là ce
qu'étaient devenus toutes ces oeuvres et
petit à petit j'ai eu un travail de
fourmi formidable avec un personnel qui
est venu nous aider
qui est venu pour d'abord les sortir de
l'endroit où ils étaient les emmener
ailleurs les emporter dans un autre lieu
et commençait un peu à revoir ce qui
pourrait être fait et justement durant
cette opération de sauvetage d
des oeuvres on a vu beaucoup de grands
élans solidarité oui tout à fait et puis
je me souvenir quand même que et le
premier ministre et le ministre de
l'intérieur et la ministre des affaires
culturelles sont venus pour constater
les dégâts et venir apporter aussi leur
soutien
on a eu un élan de solidarité gardès
vous avez vu aussi des restaurateurs
venus de paris orléans tours y en ait
pour les aider de manière bénévole
en effet durant les 72 heures
d'immersion nous nous avons fait tout un
travail en effet avec l'équipe pour
alerter finalement les restaurateurs qui
sont venus immédiatement et qui ont
permis en effet de par les premiers
soins et par par les premiers actes
qu'ils ont apporté aux oeuvres les de
les sauver en partie en grande partie
alors justement on va voir très
concrètement comment se déroule ce
travail très minutieux de restauration
d'oeuvres puisque durant ces journées
portes ouvertes ici ce week end au musée
girodet vous avez mis en place un
atelier restauration d'oeuvres on va
retrouver dans cet atelier héloïse
bruzat héloïse vous avez tout nous dire
sur ce véritable travail de fourmi et
mais oui et je vais vous dire ça en
compagnie de marie qui est montargoise
et qui fait partie de ces fabuleuses
personnes qui se sont présentées ici en
disant est ce qu'on peut aider au moment
où ou to taou je t'aime remonte cette
catastrophe culturelle comme l'a dit
jean pierre door mari ça c'est une
oeuvre alors un peu terrible c'est une
oeuvre que vous aviez restaurer avant
les inondations elle avait été restauré
en 2015 donc il faut soient-ils sophie
voilà vers le on travaille en binôme
avec sophie donc ça on venait de finir
la restauration et en 2016
elle a pris l'ol était emballé donc elle
est restée très longtemps à l'humidité
alors c'est un plâtre c'est à une
transposition en relief du radeau de la
méduse qu'est text a réalisé pour le
tombeau de jéricho dans quel état vous
l'a récupéré qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle
a cette oeuvre quand nous vous la ric
alors déjà le plâtre c'est un matériau
qui est très sensible à l'eau et qui est
armé de
la petit bois donc le bois dégager des
tanins et tout a été fragilisée dont la
surface est complètement altérée et la
soirée c'est jaune c'est jaune c'est ça
se desquame c'est pulvérulents d'accord
et la structure n'est plus suffisamment
solides pour rester en état a lancé quoi
les premiers secours les premiers ce
qu'on apporte qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
les jeunes touche mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait alors qu'au départ on a on a sorti
lolë l'oeuvre de l'eau et on l'a laissé
sécher est comme ça ne sert à rien de
d'intervenir tant que l'oeuvre est
humide donc on a attendu
balala du coup à fond la sangle et avec
des des lanières pour pas qu'elle se
démonte pas ce qu on avait vraiment
l'impression qu'elle allait partir en
différents morceaux d'accord donc la
restauration a été mené en début 2010
mita d'accord donc là elle était très
très sèche et le premier gros souci
c'était la structure donc on a été
obligé de réaliser un renfort en nid
d'abeille et tish d'inox et résines
époxydes pour pouvoir pallier à la
défaillance des latine bois qui était
complètement cassé et tac n'est plus et
concrètement on reprend une éponge alors
fait dessus
l'état n'avait tâches et la surface donc
elle apparaissait brune
donc on a déjà fait des compresses pour
essayer de d'éliminer un maximum toutes
ces colorations
après on a nettoyé en même temps les
compresses ont permis le nettoyage ils
avaient été rasées à la sortie de ce que
les boues d'inondations s'est elle reste
collée après elles deviennent quasiment
n'enleva quoi ça devient très compliqué
après il se trouvait que lors de notre
restauration on avait enlevé un badigeon
qui avait été passé sur ce sur ce relief
je l'avais en enlever mais de façon
partielle parce que il devenait il était
trop adhérents pour qu'on enlève tout et
que sans porter atteinte au support là
du coup on à l'immersion a permis que se
bat dijon qui restaient dans les creux
soit éliminé donc ça on a non j'allais
vous demandez aujourd'hui qu'on ne vous
la voyez cette oeuvre
vous ressentez quoi vous
la montargoise qui est va me porter
secours comme ça super contente parce
que je les ai vus sortie de l'inondation
elle était pour moi il était récupérable
et là maintenant je la trouve magnifique
jeu quand on s'approche de près c'est
vrai qu'on voit que l'association la
surface a souffert de toute façon le
plâtre c'est un peu dissous dans l'eau
mais à une distance raisonnable de
vision l'oeuvre est telle que je l' ai
connu en 2015
donc je suis je suis ravie quoi et ben
moi aussi je suis ravi de voir l'émotion
avec laquelle vous nous parler de cette
oeuvre
vous l'avez compris rebecca ya plein de
gens qui se sont mobilisés pour faire
revivre ces oeuvres je vais vous en
présenter d'autres tout à l'heure
évidemment à tous merci héloïse a tout
de suite effectivement beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup de solidarité autour
de la restauration de ses oeuvres il ya
quand même une question que j'ai envie
de vous poser parce qu'elle garde s on
dit souvent que les oeuvres ont dû
rester trois jours dans l'eau avant
d'être sauvé comment ça se fait d'une
part l'immersion a été totale c'est à
dire que le non seulement toutes les
tâches des réserves mail étage au dessus
étaient également inondés par au moins
un mètre cinquante et il faut imaginer
quand même que autour autour du bâtiment
et toute la ville était est et était
sous l'eau donc en effet pomper pomper
pour remettre de l'eau
sur le canal donc il a fallu en effet
que d'une part le niveau de l'eau baisse
pour que le pompage soit efficace donc
il a fallu soixante douze heures donc à
peu près de deux jours et demi pour que
l'intégralité de l'espace dans
lesquelles les les collections étaient
stockés soit vidée de son eau et donc
durant les travaux puisque finalement ce
musée était en travaux déjà au moment
des inondations est ce qu'il a fallu
réfléchir un meilleur endroit pour ce
bâtiment qui en zone inondable pour
exposer ou réserver les oeuvres je pense
que la question n'est pas là je crois
que tout de suite à la sortie de la
salle inondées il a fallu mettre les
oeuvres dans un camion réfrigéré
congelés de façon à sécher les oeuvres
avant de les emporter ailleurs donc il
ya eu tout un travail long avant
d'arriver à la restauration
il faut pas oublier non plus que le
l'immeuble eeci a été inondée en sous
sol au rez-de-chaussée puisque entre le
loue un appartement est ce que durant
les travaux de rénovation de vous avez
pris en compte ce ce bâtiment qui en
zone inondable pour mieux le rénover oui
oui c'était s'était en effet c'est en
effet une inde est un des éléments qui a
été pris en compte puisque toutes les
parties ray park puisque là nous sommes
au niveau rez de jardin à l'arrière du
bâtiment
le raid parc et tous les locaux sont des
locaux plus tôt je veux dire ou
techniques ou des ateliers de pratique
ou des ateliers techniques n'y avait
aucun espace consacré aux collections
les réserves dans ce bâtiment actuel
sont au dessus de nos bureaux dont
quasiment aussi c'est justement on va
aller faire un tour dans les réserves
tout à l'heure pour ce qui est de ce
bâtiment qui a été rénové puisque le
projet de rénovation date d'avant les
inondations j'imagine qu'il a aussi
fallu tenir compte de ce beau bâtiment
qui a toute une histoire particulière au
sein de montargis qui datent du 19e
siècle fait donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait des travaux gigantesques qui sont
les travaux de rénovation ont pour en
parler de l' architecture
donc je pense que depuis 2004 2005 on
est sur le le sujet on est arrivés en
2015 à avoir terminé le l'immobilier et
malheureusement je dis patatras il ya eu
les inondations qu'il nous faut retarder
de deux ans jean pierre door aujourd'hui
de ce bâtiment entièrement rénové
faisait bien sûr de rayonner ouvertement
du loiret de toute la région et plus que
ça nationale et internationale
on a des oeuvres qui sont partis dans le
monde entier ce musée est un musée de
france
musée national on a le label musée de
france donc je crois que maintenant on
va pouvoir offrir ce musée à toute une
population très importante
on peut en être fier c'est un patrimoine
local et régional magnifique merci
beaucoup jean pierre door justement
comme promis on va aller se rendre dans
les réserves du musée un lieu secret
qu'on le doit
on ne doit pas révéler habituellement
l'endroit exact mais on a quand même eu
l'autorisation exceptionnelle de nous y
rendre et serait bien sûr et louise
bruzat qui nous fait découvrir ce lieu
habituellement à l'abri des regards et
louise est ce que vous avez dénicher des
trésors cachés pour nous oh que oui
rebecca il y en a plein des trésors
autour de moi on a effectivement
l'immense bonheur d'être ici dans ses
réserves et je vous garantis que l'eau
ne viendra pas jusqu'ici dégrader les
oeuvres je suis avec 6 2 nuls me
feraient de bons jours mais moi je vous
accueillir ici vous êtes chargé de la
valorisation des collections ici qu'est
ce que ça vous fait vous quand vous
voyez ces réserves qui se remplissent au
fur et à mesure bah c'est déjà l'immense
plaisir de pouvoir la retrouver quelque
part l'intégrité des réserves de cette
manière là et puis ça nous fait prendre
conscience aussi du travail accompli par
tous les restaurateurs qui est un
travail immense entre le moment où on a
vu les oeuvres vraiment abîmé et on les
retrouve restaurer et puis conscience
aussi du travail qui reste à faire avant
d'ouvrir le musée you il ya de superbes
oeuvres autour de nous un honneur qui a
eu la chance de ne pas être immergé ici
tout à fait de l'école de fontainebleau
qui est peinte sur bois qui est
précieuse et qui a la chance d'avoir pu
être sauvées avant l'inondation
et puis la deuxième offre c'est une
oeuvre de fortune et du faux un élève de
jirau des qui est une acquisition durant
la fermeture voilà pour vous dire aussi
que le musée à continuer à vivre malgré
la fermeture on est d'accord que les
oeuvres qui ont été dégradées par l'eau
ne seront plus jamais les mêmes ça il
faut se le dire il faut l'accepter
c'était une prise de conscience
difficile mais douloureuse même et toute
l'équipe
est consciente qu'il ya un avant et un
après l'inondation bien sûr pour
l'histoire du musée et justement on a
une oeuvre qui témoigne vraiment bien de
ça qu'est ce que vous nous avez préparé
ici qu'est ce que vous nous avez sorti
des réserves
oui alors c'est une offre de maximilien
luce qui a la particularité d'être
peintes sur carton et donc vous imaginez
que le carton a beaucoup joué durant nos
éléments dominants dation pour vous
montrer aussi qu'il ya deux sortes de
restauration les restaurations qu'on a
pas lu un peu complète qui permet de
montrer une oeuvre mur lisible belle et
puis les restaurations qu'on appelle de
stabilisation qui sont en fait destiné à
préserver la structure à la restaurer
mais seulement la structure sont gelées
jusqu'au maquillage esthétique et ça
voilà un deuxième temps voilà pour cette
oeuvre là c'est vrai que c'est assez
flagrant ses gondoles ici là il a fallu
faire un choix les choix les choix de
restauration sont toujours des choix
quelque part philosophique et
individuelles oeuvre par oeuvre et les
restaurateurs à qui on a confié ce
tableau ont fait le choix de le
restaurer au mieux au niveau du support
mais malheureusement ne pourra pas
retrouver sa planéité c'est ça il ya des
stigmates qui vont forcément rester ça
c'est sûr et certain vous vous avez
l'air de bien vivre avec ça et dans tous
les cas je crois qu'il est pas il n'y a
pas vraiment de choix
on va on va terminer
avec un petit cadeau une petite surprise
pour nos téléspectateurs ça c'est
adorable qu'est ce que vous allez nous
montrer d'eux des chefs-d'oeuvre du
musée
évidemment des peintures de girodet sur
donc la première c'est le sommeil dans
l'union qui est une réplique d'ateliers
et au pardon olympique d'ateliers
réplique autographes
excusez moi et nous avons travaillé
dessus pendant la fermeture du musée on
peut vous dire maintenant voilà de
manière complètement inédite que c'est
une oeuvre qui a été commandé par louis
bonaparte une oeuvre illustre et la
deuxième qui est accroché juste à côté
c'est la scène de déluge aucune celle ci
c'est la réplique d'ateliers et de la
madgi rodez la scène de d'élus c'est un
tableau qui a rendu célèbre giraudet en
1806 parce qu'il a alors été comparé à
michel-ange et surtout il s'est fait
connaître comme le peintre de la
catastrophe
d'accord ou pas très étonnant qu'il se
soit passé une grosse catastrophe ici
heureuse moi le fait un malheureux
hasard mais c'est derrière le rebecca
maintenant on va pouvoir profiter
justement de toutes ces oeuvres très
bientôt
merci beaucoup et louise effectivement
on va pouvoir venir admirer ses oeuvres
ici au musée girodet parce qu'elle garde
est la directrice du musée nous
accompagne toujours durant toute cette
émission spéciale nous a rejoint
géraldine dion bonjour vous êtes
professeur d'histoire géographie au
lycée d'urzy de villemandeur vous avez
participé à un projet artistique
scolaire avec vos élèves vont en parler
dans un instant mais d'abord parce
qu'elle gardait s'il ya une question
j'ai envie de vous poser quand est ce qu
ils vinrent ouvrir officiellement ses
portes ce musée on parle du mode
décembre oui oui le musée donc ouvrir
avec la muséographie et les collections
au mois de décembre puisque en effet le
les marchés de restauration et ceux qui
sont engagés en peinture bon c'est un
petit peu plus long puisqu'il ya des
problématiques beaucoup plus lourde que
des restaurations habituel avec
deschamps si profond et donc certaines
oeuvres sont nécessite vraiment un temps
de restauration assez long donc on va
attendre d'avoir cette date normalement
courant décembre 2018
géraldine viot je le disais
vous avez mené un projet avec votre
classe une classe de première s t2a en
arts appliqués et design avec le musée
girodet sur la thématique des portraits
alors racontez nous voilà tout à fait
donc nous avons travaillé sur la
thématique des portraits dans le cadre
d'un dispositif qui s'intitule la classe
l'oeuvre c'est un dispositif national et
donc il a été initiée également par une
collègue professeur documentaliste et
lina de seine il est l'objectif de cette
classe l'oeuvre donc la classe l'oeuvre
c'est de pouvoir
présenté en fait hors de la nuit des
musées une action culturelle en
partenariat avec les musées est placée
sur le thème des portraits donc chaque
élève en groupe a étudié des portraits
de girodet justement par exemple le
portrait de madame risée qui a ses
célèbres voilà tout à fait le portrait
madame rézé donc nous avons pu avoir
accès à la correspondance d'ailleurs
entre giraud des madame rézé il s'agit
d'un portrait de commande et dans le cas
de cette commande est bien on a plus
effectivement observé comment la
commande s'étaient déroulés notamment
les négociations sur la taille du
portrait alors justement comment comment
la jeunesse peut s'approprier une oeuvre
artistique d'un peintre montargois qui
date d'il ya un siècle plus d'un siècle
donc cette jeunesse s'est approprié
justement ce dialogue entre les deux
personnages en transcrivant ce dialogue
sous la forme de sms
donc ils ont réalisé finalement un
dialogue sous la version sms et ensuite
ils ont théâtralisé
c'est à dire qu'une élève jouer madame
rézé qui recevait ses sms sur le coup et
sur la taille est une fameuse nous
amuser le 9 mai dernier on vous envoie
d'ailleurs elle les images à l'écran
parce qu'elle gardait ses importants
justement que ce musée girodet soit
ancré dans ce territoire du montargois
avec la jeunesse autour dans
l'agglomération gris et bien sûr pas
tout le travail ça c'est assez depuis
depuis assez longtemps en effet nous
nous menons un travail de médiation et
de et d'accompagnement aussi avec les
établissements scolaires mais aussi avec
d'autres établissements de des
associations pour valoriser ses
collections et aussi avoir des goûts
tout un travail en effet
d'interprétation puisque la la classe
l'oeuvre nous a permis pour nous aussi
d'avoir un regard nous renouveler
finalement sur ses collections de voir
la richesse et les manières dont
l'oeuvre de jirau d'aimer ça pourrait
être l'oeuvre de triqueti ou d'un autre
artiste de la collection ne pouvait être
interprétée compris très bien compris
d'ailleurs par les élèves et
réinterprète et est justement pour
continuer à faire vivre ce musée pour le
renouveler vous avez entrepris
d'acquérir de nouvelles oeuvres on va
retrouver héloïse bruzat qui se trouvent
dans l'atelier des nouvelles
acquisitions
on héloïse vous avez je crois de très
belles choses à nous faire découvrir
oui c'est une toute petite pièce mais
avec de très grands chefs-d'oeuvre on va
dire ça comme ça ouais on ose le mot et
je suis avec sidonie c'est pas elle qui
va me dire le contraire parce que je
sens qu'il ya de la fierté quand vous
regardez ces deux nouvelles oeuvres deux
acquisitions pour le musée girodet on a
une oeuvre de jirau des qui s'appelle
marc dauchez un mot dessus alors c'était
c'est une oeuvre exceptionnelle parce
qu'elle n'était pas réapparu depuis
la vente de l'atelier giraudet en 1825
veut dire qu'on avait perdu sa trace
exactement
voilà donc sa galerie jean françois même
qui nous l'a proposé est donc
exceptionnel aussi par sa qualité et la
deuxième de la même manière c'est une
oeuvre inédite d'henri de triqueti la
reine de saba produite en lien avec sa
grande décoration la chapelle du prince
albert à windsor et qui provient
probablement d'une très belle collection
en angleterre qu'est ce que ça va
apporter j'ai envie d'avoir ces deux
éléments en plus alors elles ont été
choisies de manière très concertée en
partenariat avec l'état qui a porté le
fonds du patrimoine et la région ne peut
rien faire exactement de juste pour rire
que tire exactement les acquisitions se
font en partenariat avec les services
d'état et de régions et puis elles vont
complété le parcours puisqu'il ya assez
peu d'oeuvres de marbre en marbre de
tripoli puisqu'on concernent
essentiellement son fonds d'atelier et
de cette période de girodet aux
alentours de 1786 18 cents la collection
est plutôt pauvre même si elle a des
chefs-d'oeuvre évidemment gilbert moi
j'ai envie d'avoir un petit peu votre
ressenti vous vous êtes montargois vous
êtes de la société d'émulation de
montargis mais moi si je vous ai demandé
de venir ce matin c'est parce que vous
avez contribué financièrement aussi à
sauver giraudet au lendemain des
inondations on a demandé aux habitants
de participer à une campagne de
financement participatif et vous vous y
êtes allé pourquoi pas écouté
effectivement nous avons reçu tout de
suite un courrier de 2,6 denis
d'ailleurs dont tous les membres de la
société d'émulation se sont mobilisés
parce que ce musée c'est un peu le nôtre
aussi puisque en 1853 quand la société a
été créée elle a été créée pour
favoriser la création d'un musée à
montargis donc tout ce qui était
adhérent à l'époque était en même temps
des mécènes voilà donc c'est un peu
notre musée et pour voilà pas liés à la
catastrophe de l'inondation c'est vrai
que quand quelqu'un se noie on engueule
après ne pas avoir appris à nager mais
on essaie de le sauver d'abord et on lui
tend une main quand même donc je crois
que beaucoup d'adhérence sont
effectivement mobilisés et la société en
tant que tel aussi votre sentiment à
vous aujourd'hui c'est quoi content
heureux
ah ben oui bien sûr avoir participé un
sauvetage comme ça c'est une chose
importante pour tout le monde pour le
gâtinais pour pour pour l'art en général
bien entendu il fallait que ça se fasse
et en espérant que ça ne se reproduira
plus jamais les leçons devront avoir été
prise
exactement et vous êtes très très
impatient comme beaucoup de gens ici
justement que le musée rouvre enfin ses
portes ce sera pour la fin de l'année
rebecca mais en attendant il ya tout ce
week-end pour en profiter tout à fait
merci beaucoup
héloïse merci à votre invité pascal
gardès effectivement un lieu le musée
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure est
un lieu qui doit se renouveler au
renouveler tout le temps plus encore
dans ce musée girodet qui vit une
véritable renaissance aujourd'hui oui
oui bah l'émission en effet de tout
musée
et surtout des musées de france était à
la fois bon les enrichissement des
collections le l'ouverture à des publics
variés et en effet bon moment à la fois
à la fermeture du musée nos avions créé
un petit espace qui était le petit musée
géré dès qu'ils étaient au coeur de la
ville et crée aussi un dispositif
itinérant avec musée nomade qui vous
permet en effet d'aller au dans des
lieux inhabituels comme des ehpad des
hôpitaux de jour où des établissements
scolaires donc on parlait des nouvelles
acquisitions également escale ouverture
décembre janvier 2019 vous allez aussi
organiser des expositions temporaires
oui oui bien sûr il ya une exposition il
ya un projet là actuellement
d'expositions temporaires qui est en
cours qui est assez lourd qui est celui
de 2,2 de présenter le salon de 1819
pour 2010 pour 2019 qui est un salon
extrêmement important à la fois pour la
halle à l'origine la naissance du
romantisme ou how avait été présentée à
la fois le radeau de la méduse de
géricault mais aussi pygmalion égalité
de 2-2 giraudet et puis il y aura bien
sûr régulièrement dans la programmation
d aider d exposition dossier qui
permettront de renouveler et de
présenter des oeuvres qui sont en
réserve ou des oeuvres qui ne sont pas
dans le parcours permanent
merci beaucoup géraldine dion un dernier
mot vous qui êtes en contact avec la
jeunesse ici à montargis et dans
l'agglomération c'est important que ce
musée soit un lieu vivant aussi
oui c'est important que ce soit un lieu
vivant et salé c'est vrai qu'avec faska
gardès et la médiatrice culturelle
anne-marie du boucher on a vraiment très
bien travaillé et la rencontre directe
avec les oeuvres c'est une richesse
énorme pour les pour les élèves
merci beaucoup à tout les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci nous
avons accueilli ici dans votre
merci aux équipes techniques qui ont
permis la réalisation de cette émission
spéciale où va ce kit est justement ce
midi en musique avec la jeunesse puisque
on en parlait à l'instant avec les
violons des miss est un orchestre ils
sont quinze jeunes gens ils vont nous
jouer un morceau on les écoute et puis
nous on se dit à bientôt
pour
oh
oui